I don't know where to put all the things
[Applause]
[Music]
and I am here with Jen so you guys know
that I am a mess like I my life is
always just in shambles there's stuff
everywhere
so bonding here ago I met Jen and she
came in with her team and they
completely reorganized my house yes and
you're not a mess okay definitely did
help hello you're being the way nothing
is where it belongs
nothing has a home nothing makes sense
I've got electronics in the kitchen
I've got kitchenware in my office I
don't know where to put all the things
[Music]
you guys love organization or you need
inspiration to become organized you guys
have to go check out our Instagram do
you want to talk about like some of the
stuff you guys post yes of course so for
our Instagram at life in general with a
J we do a lot of before and afters so we
come into spaces whether it be garages
or closets or tech spaces or kitchens
which we'll show you today they're
really fun so we basically come in pull
everything out categorize sort and then
install it back in with that new system
what's the first thing that you do when
you come into a space when we first come
in we meet and then talk to you about
kind of the flow of the room like what's
working for you we see the space but the
biggest thing is just kind of wanting to
know your vision like what's the space
for what do you need in that space and
then a lot of it is just once we get to
work and pulling everything out really
seeing everything you'd be surprised of
what you don't need what you don't use
what you have a hundred of it was
actually shocking so like I kind of just
went away for like a few minutes and
then it came back and everything one
outlet they pull every single he's a
thing that's that's somewhere and then
you just sort of like sort through I got
rid of a lot of stuff you did and we
donate to a lot of really great
charities too which was really great
somebody's projects is you guys
so when I first moved into this place
there was a closet that wasn't built out
so I think that was the biggest thing to
tackle because not only had I afforded
so much stuff inside of this space you
guys completely took all of that
reorganized it and then turned it into
the closet and yeah it's beautiful I'm
really happy with how it turned out I
think for us to coming into the space
and learning what your real needs are
and then seeing that we needed to build
it out so we brought in california
closets to really make that space a
beautiful place for you to have and then
of course with all your office stuff and
your supplies and all your little tech
pieces and hundreds of thousands of
legos you know making sure that we have
the home for everything stays that way
is really important we wanted to go
through and do some reactions to
before-and-after photos because some of
these I haven't seen at all actually
yeah
so you just sent them to my phone where
do we even start it should we do oh my
gosh we were opening the cabinet and
stuff was flying at us this isn't even
something that I could comprehend when I
first opened that it was shocking it was
just like Hershey's cocoa up there oh my
goodness do you want to come say hi oh
you are a part of the team I am a part
of the team there's a lot of us and
depending on the vibe of the team it's
definitely important to creating like a
perfect functional space with yeah but
what was one of the thing that you most
fell out of your efforts on well I don't
I knew you were like full of like tech
and everything and all that so the
office was awesome to the built out
speed app when you first walk in was
really cool to see the transformation
but I love junk drawers and it's okay
yeah it's so I've never loved a joy
look at this but it has a home right
everyone take a screenshot of this video
and tweet it to Burnie and Gavin free
right now sharpies pong balls from near
palm which actually ends up being water
palm do you know something else this is
this has been new since you were last
here but I do you want some this
organizer is so great this is where the
snacks reside oh my god Chris Oh get in
get in here see what's in there look a
lot Lacroix this is my favorite thing so
took pictures and chuckling pictures I'm
working on my juggling before but
healthy bars are full of chocolate and
candy does alcohol expire because no guy
he's got a sweater
this here is a favorite in real life
like everything is so great here's all
of ROS little nerdy nummies accessories
it's just crazy for something that
doesn't actually be together
oh the mixers have a home it's just the
best part is seeing what it look like
before I mean wow you ever see the tech
drawer there's no longer
[Music]
Jordan's favorite it's so perfect
maybe what do you think about that
[Music]
it used to be well there was something
here I had like this awful shelf thing
you what I think it was just like a cube
because I was displaying like my mr.
Miyamoto a Nintendo 3ds I had like my
display of like my favorite Xbox like I
don't that shelf it was yeah I was we
categorized every item that she has and
then we built these drawers just all the
different tech stuff as well you can see
everything so before there is kind of
shoved in and then we just categorize
everything and these are just really
great to have and easily accessible as
well so great now if I everything when I
say hey weirded up with that SD card
described that's pretty bit see you guys
may have seen this in Linus's tour but
this is this whole closet like all of
this was all built out like this wasn't
here before
garage garage garage it's a process so
this is my Lego collection this isn't
the entire collection but this is some
stuff that I still wanted to build that
I had time to build I don't know if I
ruined this one was the last time do you
guys remember what this looked like yeah
we do
[Music]
I can't wait to have an actual closet
now I just don't want to wear socks
I don't want to touch them those are
everything this is my favorite my shoes
have a home I've never actually wore
these the only time I wore them I would
try them on in the store but I thought
one day so like all my backpacks have a
home all your teeth oh my are everything
is perfect everything is so organized
can't believe what this looked like
before can I help you
Maddy loves it hi
[Music]
let's just have a good song normally
people just like you know like punch it
uh and some people say socks have
feelings if I'd go that far but I
wouldn't we just like to place them
together we tuck them in and they're
beautiful so we do a file fold as well
so instead of shoving same thing daddy
look at my swimsuit
daddy loves it now do you want to go
swimming no I wouldn't do that to you my
camera bags are over here I need oh my
gosh your fins fooled it too loosely in
there - it's like forted nice and you
can't even see it see that's where you
climb you just you know get away it was
like there's nothing coming in - no no
no you can stretch a Pico for walking
over here I was like I think I've been a
notice maybe this is a note no but so
sorry yeah maybe it's like just saying
why did you buy leather pants you know
you're not gonna wear them do you think
I like camo well that is our tour
there's still so many more places that
we didn't even show you but the before
and after pictures is what I really want
to show you guys because I mean you guys
did my entire house and then it really
did change my life just having just the
peace of mind of things not everywhere
and knowing where everything is yes
loving everything you have okay well
thank you so much I'll put Jenn's links
in the description you guys go check her
out life in general or her Instagram is
such an inspiration and even like
watching all of your stories and stuff
though guys like the process of doing
all of this is it's so amazing and I
think they're gonna love it thank you
Jordan do wanna come say bye
[Music]